Mm,
curiosity has been often referred to as
closing a knowledge gap and this goes
back to Berlin's.
Work,
goes back to a lot of work being done by
Lippman and his colleagues presently
would distinguish between two forms of
curiosity,
interest,
epistemic curiosity and knowledge gap,
curiosity,
that probation they call it.
The reason that they call it deprivation
is because that is has been an argument
that if you are curious,
there is a certain kind of negative
feeling that you experienced before.
Your curiosity is satisfied and once you
have this answer,
you feel a relief and a positive feeling
comes over you.
We argued that if you are interested and
you are searching for more information,
that is a rewarding experience and you
do not necessarily or you're unlikely to
have an adversity feeling except you can
have negative feelings develop because
you have a problem in your search,
but that's different than trying to
close the knowledge gap.
The way that I can best demonstrate you,
how we consider curiosity and interest
to be different is by telling you to
think about when you read a detective
story.
When you read a detective story,
the minute you find out that who
actually is the murderer,
you might not even want to finish your
book and compare that to reading glad,
say Harry Potter or some really well
constructed book that you are not simply
trying to find out a knowledge gap.
You are interested in many of the
characters who are interested in the
ideas,
you are interested in the relationships
and you will keep on reading that book.
Not only is the length of time different
and the aversion different,
but there are also the purpose is is
different like when you are interested
you,
you are searching for a lot of
information,
not just a specific information to close
the knowledge gap.
Now there are some
unanswered issues about this.
For example,
what happens if you have interest in a
content,
but that is a knowledge gap that you're
closing.
Is that now different from just being
curious and we argued that it is because
for example,
at a bridge expert who loves playing
bridge,
he is reading a book with many,
many puzzles.
Okay?
Solving beach hands.
He goes and solves and knowledge gap and
then continuous going onto other
questions,
other puzzles,
because he has that individual interest
in the content that propels him to go on
for further activity.